ضموا الينا من عمان لواء فايزه دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي وفايز مرحبا
بك معنا من اين بدايه ترجح مصدر هذه
المسيرات
وما نوع الاهداف من وجهه نظرك التي
استهدفتها
يعني الان اخر تقرير يتحدث عن طائرات يوجي
22 وهي طائرات
اوكرانيه يتم تصنيعها من قبل شركه
اوكرانيه لديها مواصفات محدده اولا هي
تسير بسرعه 150 كيلو متر بالساعه
تطير لمده سته ساعات الى ارتفاع 5000 متر
يضاف الى ذلك
مداها الاقصى 800 كيلو متر
قادره على حمل عشرين كيلو متفجرات
وتعمل في كافه الظروف الجويه وبالتالي بما
انه قدم نوع الطائره يمكن الان كما قلت
هذه المعلومات المتاحه عن هذه الطائره
وبالتالي ما هي طبيعه الاهداف هذه طائره
طائره انتحاريه
عندما نتحدث لماذا اقول انتحاريه
لانها وظفت في هذه العمليه بالذات تكون
انتحاريه لان عليها ان تقطع مسافه 800
كيلو متر وهو الحد الاقصى للطيران لهذه
الطائره ومع ذلك
ومع ذلك بحسب العاجل الذي يظهر على
شاشاتنا الان رويترز تنقل عن مصدر في
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه انه لا علاقه
لاوكرانيا بهجوم الطائرات المسيره على
موسكو لكننا نتوقع المزيد يعني هذا المصدر
يقول لا علاقه لاوكرانيا لكنه يتوقع
المزيد من هذه الهجمات هنالك تصريح ايضا
اشار اليه حسان مسعود من رئيس الاستخبارات
من يهاجم كيف سيندم وهنالك تصريح كذلك من
مسؤول عسكري يقول ينبغي ان يعاني سكان او
يدعي ان يعيش سكان موسكو ما يعيشه سكان
ما الذي ينبؤه يعني هذا الهجوم بالمسيرات
على موسكو اليوم ماذا ينبئنا عن طبيعه هذه
المرحله من الحرب
يعني هذه المرحله هي مرحله تصعيد محموم من
قبل الجانبين نعم التصعيد الروسي اوسع
نطاقا اكثر تاثيرا اكثر كثافه اكثر فاعليه
ولكن بالمقابل
الجانب الاوكراني يحاول ان يقول ان الذراع
الاوكراني طويله عندما تصل الى كييف نحن
نستطيع الوصول الى موسكو بغض النظر عن
الفارغ في عدد الطائرات او الصواريخ او ما
شابه ذلك الان القدرات الصاروخيه غير
موجوده بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني بالمطلق
الوسيله الوحيده
لتستطيع الوصول الى موسكو واطراف موسكو هي
استخدام هذا النوع من الطائرات لانها كما
قلت لك هي وظفت في هذه الرحله لتكون
انتحاريه لانها لا تستطيع العوده لانها
تكون قد قطعت كافه المسافه المصممه لها
هذا النوع من الطائرات ولكنها هي رساله
الى روسيا اننا نستطيع الوصول الى العاصمه
الروسيه كما تقوم انتم بالوصول الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه التاثير المادي كما
لاحظنا محدود وسيبقى محدود لانها عندما
تطير 800 كم لن تستطيع ان تحمل اكثر من 20
كيلوغرام من المتفجرات يضاف الى ذلك انا
منطقه العاصمه الروسيه موسكو محصنه بصوره
كبيره بعظم الدفاع الجوي متعدده منها اول
اسم 400 قيل انه نشرت بطاريه اس 300 نظام
بانتسير او نظام المراقبه الفضائيه
الالكتروني ولواء الدفاع الجوي الخاص شكرا
لك